milla jovovich is coming in of course
star of the new cowboy movie hello in
theaters this Friday very very exciting
times what's going on not much well a
lot a lot a huge a huge amount isn't
much and a lot right not much in the
momentary so now listen I'm sitting with
you fine gentleman's so that's a lot
that's true a lot of actors hate to
impress a lot of hate corn and it's just
our show it's not most of them like no
but I've told myself it's pressing
Jeffrey I see well yeah it's not
personal that's for sure
it's just you know I think hearing
yourself repeat yourself over and over
is not the funnest thing in the world
and I prefer to listen to people anyway
so yeah you know to hear myself talk
about me is pretty boring myself I asked
you to talk about a project it's hard
you know it was fun like there's only so
much you can say about the project it's
like what do you say about it it's good
really is a good project it's a lot of
fun actually when I was a usually when I
go to see my movies I get really kind of
obsessive over myself and that's like a
very actor thing like totally
self-absorbed and I can't really enjoy
the movie but this time around for some
reason like I just went with it and it
was like so fun and so action-packed and
funny and David Harbour is just so
hilarious and everybody's so good I
really had a great time so what do you
watch yourself and like dissect yourself
I love watching it no no I checked
myself it's like it's like hearing your
voice I'm gonna totally age myself it's
like hearing your voice on the answering
machine but like times 100 then you have
to see yourself too so right that's like
what yeah back in the day when you would
record the message on your answering
machine
oh I just have to leave first kidding
because if you if you tried to mix it
you just keep fixing it and fixing it
and fixing it
yeah normal thing was like because
before texting obviously like if you ran
to the store you'd be like I'm just
running to the store or be right back
you do the answering machine oh yeah I'm
in the shower be right back leave a
message
I'll be out like
three minutes thick literally everything
you did you had to leave an outgoing
message just reporting I used to try to
make them funny
you did do character you totally do
funny ones as well yeah I look back
though and I don't think they were
particularly fool no no they were a
reverend did really bad
you'd be a reverend on your own
answering machine yeah I was just
embarrassing yeah but even worse than
that yeah I don't remember but like you
know I don't remember if I actually do
it yeah I just saw but if I said could
you be a Reverend Jim sounds like it was
certainly worse yeah I have an ability
to humiliate myself that most people
can't you see an actor oh I don't think
that's like acting 101 number one rule
of acting is be prepared to humiliate
you know any roles for ever
any roles for 50-year old men who blank
a lot in one eye so um and yeah I like
the original better if you want the true
the British office to do stop it you're
a British office person much more Wow
I've only seen I think I might have to
do now why you don't like I mean I like
it but the American office is so far
superior no no no and I'll tell you why
because Ricky Gervais is just doesn't
seem like a nice guy okay on that show
Steve Carell was like innocent he was
just oblivious but he was like sweet I
see sure you mean the David Brent
character which is Ricky's character you
think David is a jerk yeah Steve Carell
is character yes he's not a jerk he
means well yeah you means well I see
something endearing about him well David
self-centeredness is what made him so
great like he was so wrapped up in
himself and such an ass Steve Carell
he's completely self-centered but he's
endearing who's that kid he's like
literally a four-year-old always he
doesn't think about anyone but himself
right but like but innocent but the way
a four-year-old does yes in a sense that
they had to hurt where Ricky Gervais is
kind of felt like he was trying to hurt
you right that's why I like I think you
just explained why I like to push
because you're not disagreeing with that
right plus they weren't as good looking
in the British office they didn't dress
quite as well they were just and there
was always I got more good looking as
the seasons went on and the American
always had a lot more episodes to do but
they would do like different camera
things in different situations I guess
the opposite so I just literally did
like the the American office all over
again it was hard work it took me three
weeks but I had to do it and like the
finale like what was up with I mean did
you guys see no I've seen yeah little
moments of it what was up with Steve
Carell I mean I just felt like it would
have been better just not to have him at
all yeah I think felt so weird like so
why was it weird no at the end because
he didn't do anything he wasn't Michael
Scott he was like a pale imitation of
himself like a shadow of a man I bet
that they weren't thinking about the leg
we watched that series I felt like he
was contractually obligated to be there
and that was it how many seasons that
you know after a while yeah you probably
up to 24 episodes or not you're like all
right enough with this well he that's
like one of the greatest shows of all
time how could you let him know you
might be like I'm done doing this
character you might be sick of it after
all those years one last hurrah he also
I think that when that show was on like
when the office and the American office
was on especially towards the end I
don't think people realized how good it
was in the sense that like I started
rewatching it recently too and just
going oh my god the show age is perfect
literally like one of the most brilliant
pieces of yeah I don't realize it I
really I realized in like the last month
that the American office is gonna be one
of those sitcoms is around for the end
of this program like no one's gonna go
see how boy everyone's gonna re-watch
the office because how boy does it come
out till Friday some people writes like
really get through the office because
like I'm so excited for Hellboy I can't
contain myself it's all I'm thinking
about what am I gonna do to pass the
time all the offices again on the way to
Hellboy you could watch the entire
British office and Sally
that's a three hours of content total I
like I saw something about the making of
help with everything I always played the
lead but they were interviewing him at
harbors yeah yeah but actually was
really good
he was just yeah so I was listening to
David Harbor like explain the makeup
because it's far more practical effects
than people realize right yeah it's it's
less CGI Marshall who directed it I mean
he's really known for his practical
effects can you watch the descent it's
like it's so amazing but it's like a
bunch of dudes like with masks and
Vaseline all over like crawling around
like doing crazy stuff but what's that
descent the descent yeah understand it's
like one of the best horror films ever
oh yeah yeah it's good okay it's really
good it's about like cave divers like by
the way like who would ever do that it's
ridiculously ever I mean that's
literally like one of my biggest
nightmare my until I get stuck in a
crevasse in a cave like miles below the
earth that's supposed to be funny I'm
like what there's a photo of a guy who
got stuck there it was something like in
Utah wherever and he got stuck and they
couldn't get him out and all you see is
his feet sticking back out of the hole
and he wound up dying in there because
they couldn't pallate they almost pulled
it out and then they literally my worst
nightmare but you'll always watch
claustrophobic movies like that right
well like you want to watch movies like
that because of your innate fear of it
that's what was so great about the
descent but yes so I mean Neil comes
from like a background of practical
effects and like really making stuff
happen on the day rather than doing it
in post which was so great and David
Harbour I mean he was in makeup for like
three hours every morning in like 40
pounds of prosthetics my question I guys
listen to him talking about doing like
he wakes up at 2:30 in the morning goes
in at 3:30 to put all this Hellboy
makeup on you guys aren't shooting too
because I was saying even like a normal
like a normal indie movie like about a
family having dinner you're still
working 15 hours a day right you know
but add on top of that like three four
hours of makeup
before you start work and it's like when
do you have even time to sleep can you
sleep in a makeup chair when people are
doing all that stuff to you or what do
you do in the body again yeah you can a
lot of people definitely go to sleep
especially when they do like the
prosthetics on the face and stay you got
a tune out a little bit because also
those suits get super claustrophobic
right when you're we're I mean he was
talking about the fact that like there
was just so much between him and like
the world outside you know he had like
so much suit on like you can't feel
anything have you ever done anything
with serious prosthetics like to that
extent I did once in the last Resident
Evil the final chapter they aged me to
be like 90 years old and so I went
through like six hours of prosthetics
and it was it was pretty crazy because I
get really obviously we all understand
from this conversation I get super
claustrophobic but you know it takes it
to another level because you're
completely you know padded you know
you're afraid you won't be able to
breathe
well definitely like all those face
casts and stuff like they have to do
like half and then on the top part and
then half on the bottom because I can't
do this thing like I get terrified
terrified but saying that like I have to
say it was one of those liberating like
scenes for me when I played the old lady
because you have this mask on so in a
way you could do anything like you know
you're just you're just not even like
worried about it I don't know it gave me
like this sense of freedom which was
fine and David was talking about that
too like how it was almost like this
liberating feeling like having a mask on
well you it will you old through the
whole movie or is it only part of it
that you did did that make up for in
yeah it was like it was a couple of
scenes yes so it was like a week out of
the schedule kind of thing I've seen
like footage when people are getting
molded for the faces or whatever that
they do the full face and to the extent
that there's just like a straw yeah I'm
out of there man once when I did a movie
about Joan of Arc and it was like the
old-school like face masks and they had
like two tubes up my nose for like
straws up my nose to breathe and how
long was that really I mean it's like
takes like half an hour to have this
thing over your face and I literally
thought I was going I would have a panic
attack no I was litter
my heart was racing I once they got it
off I was like never again do you ever
have that what you feel like sometimes
I'm laying in bags I'm such a bad
sleeper I have to sit up there's like I
take a deep breath so it's like I can't
breathe deep I'm laying on my back I
think it's just panic or perhaps bad
memories I don't know that's actually
repression no I just can't breathe
properly like what I'm that no no I'm
okay
probably like a medical doctor and you
can't breathe I breathe better when I
sit up
yeah but I mean it's that hold
claustrophobic things if you have
nothing able to breathe
no that's right people sleep laying down
most people can breathe fine laying down
on my side because everybody lays down
they lay down to go to sleep it's
comfortably yes so what's the while I
saw a problem take a deep breath and
it's the coffin to probably like you
should keep it okay I want to be
cremated
that's the worst the idea of laying
there waking up and realizing oh [ __ ]
and what if you wake up in the cremation
well they would actually put like little
like pulleys and Joe oh yeah I think
they do that Finns like where do they
buried so many people alive the not the
idea to put a bell in right and you go
how many didn't have the Bell before
they finally like realize we should have
a bell
how many fingernails and coffin lids did
it take before they're like let's have a
bell system right this is we're not
fully in the movie the nun that came out
like a few months back I want to see
that okay and they use that with the
with the bell and there's like this
scene where you just hear like just
little Bell everybody else is asleep and
you're like oh I want to see this guy I
want to see that like you're on no one -
yeah that looks good the vanishing wants
your children I'm like my daughter is
like I keep seeing these scary things on
YouTube and I'm like they've done this
movie a million times there's always
like some late and she's like what do
you mean what's it about
who's children I'm like everybody's
children you know she died violently her
kid was killed something like that right
now she's back and she's gonna get
revenge but yeah you still want to go
see it cuz it just looks I want to see
that I pet sematary the new pet cemetery
is supposed to be pretty good right yeah
did you plan went to see the original in
the theaters when I was like way too
young to probably see that
by you no no it wasn't original right it
was like what 89 88 or something I was
like 12
yeah I vaguely remember that I remember
the book and I'm in the movies when you
got home I know Morehead like every
Stephen King book million times I hunt
the animals is difficult to pull off
because you do one wrong move and it's
laughable right right when you have like
haunted cats chasing you and stuff
saying that like Cujo
I literally still to this day prepare
myself for like being locked in my car
because there's a killer dog outside
it's the weirdest thing like I carry
like protein bars and like popcorn in my
bag and like extra water in the car just
because that book affected me so much I
was like if my childrenht ever get stuck
in a car with a killer dog I need to
have water your survivalist except for
killer dogs in the book I don't remember
where was the car that they were sorry
on a farm or something and it was
priests cellphones and there was like
the air conditioner was broken and the
kid ended up dying anyway so how that's
right that he's so good he's good
isolating Stephen Gerald's game we're
playing that kinky sexual game and the
woman's tied up to the bed and they're
in the woods no jobs get was a book yeah
yeah she's just laying there and the
door is open and she's in the woods
isolated and her [ __ ] dead husband so
it's genius
that's literally a master he's a master
we did 6 Resident Evil movies yes and
then the franchise has done yes when you
after the sixth movie cuz we're just
talking about Steve Carell is probably
not that dissimilar from him deciding
that character is over is there any kind
of panic
that sets in going like oh my god like I
don't know what life after Resident Evil
funny you should mention that because
this goes straight back to the office
okay everything goes back to the office
of course but literally right before I
got the offer for Hellboy I was kind of
going through a bit of a depression
after the whole Resident Evil thing
closed up because I was like I felt like
Jim Halpert I was like what am I going
to do with all this useless information
in my head
like right you know like I know so much
about doing action like I can bring a
lot to the table on an action movie I
have like 20 years of experience and
like now it's done so I was really happy
like do my thing again I'm like yeah use
all this experience for something right
yeah because you got trained in like
everything for Resident Evil right yeah
well it's I do so many stunts in those
movies you know so it's a lot of
physical training tonight do you end up
on movie sets : cos they're kickboxing
in this movie the best of both worlds
because my character in this movie she's
like more of an airbender than like an
action kick butt girl so it was it was
awesome because I got to live my dream
of airbending you know they never made a
sequel to Last Airbender and I was
really upset because I really wanted to
airbend and I was hoping they're
building airbending well you can't see
it but like it's like like take the
earth or water or whatever you're and
then you just like manipulate it it's
like DDP yoga throw it from the air like
you shape it and then you just like get
it to like where it's like perfect and
then you like shoot it at somebody it's
like it's like shooting gas at people
the earth Jim was Jim was airbending
before you came in the studio I have to
ask you Mila did you when you walked in
here this morning and don't worry about
being rude do is there any smells or
anything that you were like the studio
is not the freshest or was it okay well
I mean yeah no I was at MTV yesterday it
wasn't the freshest either sorry but
this is not it's not the fresh it's not
like I walked in and I was like wow it's
so refreshing where people work in small
rooms right - you know maybe it needs to
be vacuumed if it is the back of the rug
it's the rug Jim my why what's what's
really going the filtration system
inside Jim's body is not the best
they're blaming me because I passed a
while ago super happy awkward you smell
something like maybe I won't say
anything like you leave here going like
did you smell like weed a Jim and Sam
this is so much less awkward we like it
to be on the table dissipate at the rate
I'd hoped
hey you parents work for Brian DePalma
which I wanted to ask you do you still
keep in touch never do you not
my parents were housekeepers for Brian
DePalma okay so no no do you did you
like it said you know I mean not really
I was like the housekeeper's kid living
off the garage so so when you start
acting you didn't connect with them and
say it's me no no because there were
there multiple housekeepers and things
like that um no it was my mom and dad we
were like living on site and um you know
I but there was quite a lot the house
was being rented to lots of like movie
stars and things like John Travolta
stayed there and my parents were
housekeepers for him and Christopher
Reeve stayed there and I like played
with his son his because I was like what
like six at the time so that way you
were able to get into show business
young because like it was fairly not
attainable but it wasn't this sort of
mystery you know I think like a lot of
kids look at TV and movies and stuff and
there's looking at it going like that's
some other world over here they don't
that's mind you I didn't and I didn't
know who any of these people were you
know I did yeah six my parents knew but
definitely like none of them ever like
gave me a break or anything right no I
just meant like mentally in the sense
that this happens to normal people
because I know some of the people that
happened to that what what's happening
to you what being an actor oh yeah you
know some actors know you new actors
before you became an actor I mean your
parents worked for them right so we have
different from like knowing that it's
not like we came in or like what's up
how's it going yeah melee
diet coke from the fridge like they're
like no that's actually your job yeah
you get two diet cokes from the fridge
did your parents like Brian DePalma um
you know it's it's a it's a funny story
because my mom was a movie star in the
Soviet Union in the 70s so when she came
to America with my father she was like
28 like super gorgeous super glamorous
and I think in the back of her mind she
kind of thought like oh yes I'm like
quote unquote the housekeeper but as
soon as he sees me he's gonna like tell
me to put my tray down and like come sit
down with the company right and that
didn't happen so it was you know it was
it was hard for me to see my mom like so
disappointed and you know it definitely
affected me I ended up when I had my
first big paycheck I got her a Jaguar
for her birthday
did she ever act in the States a little
bit and so she ends up seeing brain
diploma at a gas station in her Jaguar
with like these covers of magazines that
I was on in her trunk she's like hello
Brian I mean the fact that he even
remembered I don't he probably didn't
even remember her like she's like trying
to prove something anything I don't know
who this person thought to be if you're
acting in the Soviet Union and then you
come it's kind of hard to probably
change well cuz obviously her English
wasn't great and back in the 8th I mean
we're talking like 1980 1981 like it was
all Russian spies or nothing you know
what did she what kind of stuff that you
do in the Soviet Union was she like on
soap on television when she moved films
and stage yeah Shakespeare man have you
gone back I've gone back a few I mean
quite a lot mostly for work yeah to
Russia yeah okay do you speak any or no
yeah yeah I speak Russian I figured you
because you did the accent pretty good
well yeah that's my mo I figured that
yeah yeah yeah I speak Russian and you
know my my kids speak Russian so I
really want to make sure that they
remember there
when you find out you had to do a
British accent for Hellboy were you
excited by this or were you going like
yeah terrified because obviously that's
like a thing that's like a rite of
passage for an actor like everyone has
to do a British accent at some point and
you've got to kill it right so you know
for me definitely that was that was like
my stunt training that was like I spent
like a few hours every day for months
like just going over the lines over them
over and over and over and over till I
like had some semblance of comfort with
everything what was the hard was like
one word or some that was really hard to
get yes it was like all these like oh
and like swoon and like Bourne rights
like and I'm doing it really horribly
yeah you're born did you I would
literally walk around doing that born
born born born born okay
would be like oh my god because you also
don't want to sound like a cartoon
character right like you'd want to sound
like it's a put on like ridiculous
British accent well yeah I mean I worked
with a great coach though Vicky Hanlon
and she also worked with Sasha Sasha
Lane who's in the movie and yeah she was
wonderful but you know anything you do
you just have to do it over and over and
over again I just did you try did you
take the British accent with you meaning
like when you weren't shooting were you
still speaking in the accent because you
didn't want to lose it stop Jim you're
not sounding British when you keep
saying right you keep saying the word
right and you don't sound British it's
not and it's not organic Shamy but did
you like were you afraid of losing it or
did you get to a place where you're so
comfortable you could go in and out um I
wasn't speaking in normal life with the
British accent because there was also
like a thing when I got to set there was
like a couple of questions like should
it be a British accent or should it be
something else and I was like
after you working for like three months
every day on this British accent and you
might potentially change it so yeah
there was like some conversations about
that plus you know you've pretty much
like work all day and go home and drop
that asleep right get up really early
the next morning and work again so it
wasn't much time for like hanging out
with people after do they ever have you
redo any takes like today like now the
accent didn't was not really yeah I mean
there was a there was somebody on set
that was always kind of just listening
just to people's accents and stuff which
is great too and British people will
call it that's very very good
are you worried at all or is anybody
with the movie worried at all about the
hardcore fanbase that's already built up
from the last two movies you know there
are expectations attached to it oh
definitely there are you know I loved
the original Hellboy movies for sure and
big fan actually Ron Perlman and I just
did a movie together he's in Monster
Hunter with me so you know I was super
happy about that but at the same time
Mike Minneola who created the the comics
he was there on set he helped write the
script so he was like very very involved
with the whole process so I think fans
are gonna love this version of the movie
because it really is so much closer to
the original graphic novels like tonally
and character wise I think people will
be very impressed with you know the
homage is that were we're paying to the
graphic novels
one more gemandsam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
SiriusXM app
[Music]